a third international attempt to
evacuate more civilians from ukraine's
besieged mario pool steel plant is
underway but the un says no more details
will be given about the operation so as
not to compromise its possible success
british intelligence says russian forces
are continuing a ground assault on the
plant despite promising a ceasefire the
wife of one ukrainian commander said
fighters inside the azov style plant had
vowed to stand until the end
the battle for ours of style continues
this video released by the far right
azov regiment shows heavy shelling on
ukraine's last stand in the besieged
city of mariopol
russia says it is ready for a ceasefire
to allow a humanitarian corridor out of
the steel plant but ukrainian fighters
claim otherwise
for the third day in a row the enemy has
broken through the territory of the azov
style plant where heavy fighting
continues
once again the russians violated the
promise of a truce and did not allow the
evacuation of civilians who continue to
hide from the shelling in the azov style
plant's basement
yet the u.n has confirmed that it has
successfully evacuated hundreds more
from mario pole during a brief ceasefire
on wednesday
we are accompanied by 11 buses filled of
civilians women children and elderly who
wants who are seeking safe heaven
those who have made it out
are relieved to finally be safe
but they are also worried about the ones
left behind
i don't know who to ask to get them out
of there to get them out of there if
they don't they will all be killed
there may be hope of a fresh ceasefire
holding
a u.n convoy on its way to mario poll is
hoping to use this to evacuate more
people
and we can cross now to our
correspondent in lev emmanuel
emma it seems russia has ramped up its
assault on the steel plant can you tell
us more about the situation there right
now
well indeed russia denies that there's a
ground fight on the other side steel
plan but british intelligence confirms
that this is happening and ukrainian
armed forces
also
say that fighting is happening in the
other style steel plant with
ukrainian intelligence officials saying
that
someone an electrician gave away maps of
the underground maze of other stars to
russian troops allowing them to know
from which
part of the plant they could enter
this maze but the forces the ukrainian
forces currently inside the other style
plant we
it is believed uh that at least two
thousand soldiers are still uh holding
the positions there well uh they say
they would not uh surrender with uh the
wife of one of the commander of the uh
as of battalion the as a regiment with
she's
also holding its position there saying
that her husband uh
said
goodbye and say to her and that they
would hold their positions until the
very very end so fightings are happening
and of course this is uh putting in
geoparty all efforts of a humanitarian
evacuation there
now a three-day truce was supposed to go
into effect on thursday to allow
people to get to safety are we seeing
any evacuations happening right now
well it has been a few days that people
have indeed been evacuated i think by
now around 500 people have made it out
safely out of a mario ball not only out
of the
steel plant but also out of devastated
mariupol but there's still
hundreds of people who are
parked in that steel plant women
children elderly people some in very uh
bad shape very poor conditions they've
been staying there for more than two
months without saying uh seeing daylight
and they too
need
need an out from this situation there's
also it is believed that hundreds of
soldiers are wounded and they are there
some of them are trapped under rubbles
and
the u.n said there was an operation
underway but they're not giving away
more information so as not to compromise
this operation
emma president zelinski has issued a
quite a stark warning that the
humanitarian situation not just in mario
paul but across all of ukraine is
growing increasingly dire let's take a
quick listen to what he said
if we take only the medical
infrastructure to date russians have
destroyed or damaged almost 400 health
facilities these are hospitals maternity
wards outpatient clinics
in the temporarily occupied areas of
ukraine in the east and south the
situation with access to medical
services and medicine is just
catastrophic
even the simplest medications are
missing
russia has brought problems to ukraine
and europe that we could not have
imagined a few months ago
okay calling it catastrophic emma what
more can you tell us about the current
situation across the whole of ukraine
well beyond medical facilities being
shelled you can imagine that
people from the east would also seek
treatment in safety in central or
western ukraine but facilities are
overwhelmed by the amount of people in
need of medical treatment you have to
imagine within the country there's over
7.5 million
internally displaced people some of them
coming from
areas worst affected by the fighting so
here in navy the hospital hospitals are
also overwhelmed with
war injuries they have to treat here
added to that there is uh
there is regular shelling on
infrastructures also in central ukraine
in western ukraine and for example when
a power station power plant is affected
then it can also affect medical services
so the whole country is left reeling by
the russian aggression
dw correspondent emma shaz in levith
thanks so much
let's take a look now at some of the
other developments in the ukraine
conflict
the united nations world food programme
is warning of global hunger crises if
key ukrainian ports remain closed the
agency is calling for the re-opening of
black sea harbors saying they are a key
link in global food security ukraine is
one of the world's leading exporters of
grain
an international conference hosted by
poland and sweden has raised six and a
half billion dollars in pledges to help
ukraine eu officials who are also
sponsoring the event say ukraine needs a
new marshall plan to help rebuild the
country president zielenski launched a
global fundraising website at the forum
saying every donation matters
israel's prime minister says russia's
president vladimir putin has apologized
for remarks made by his foreign minister
who said adolf hitler had jewish blood
naftali bennett said putin made the
apology during a phone call
now one of ukraine's biggest victories
against the invading russian forces has
been the claimed sinking of the warship
moskva last month
now an anonymous u.s official has told
media that washington shared
intelligence with ukraine about the
ship's location
the moskva was the flagship of russia's
black sea fleet the u.s says it had no
knowledge of ukraine's plans to attack
the moskva with anti-ship missiles
though reports say it helped pinpoint
the moskva's position
the biden administration has been
ramping up intelligence sharing as well
as shipments of weapons to ukraine while
avoiding direct conflict with russia
and for more we can speak now with
gustav
senior policy fellow at the european
council on foreign relations and an
expert on the russian military welcome
to dw
the loss of the moskva was hugely
significant for russia how is this news
about possible u.s involvement likely to
be going down in moscow
uh well the fact that the u.s would
share our target data with ukraine is
known since the beginning of march
and it is it was highly likely at the
thinking that u.s
signal intercepts might have something
to do with it because ukrainians don't
have sensors that reach so far out into
the black sea to actually pinpoint and
see
uh that there's a warship uh
probably in trouble uh or distracted by
by some cold kind of damage internally
that would provide a suitable target for
their cruise missiles for their
anti-ship missiles
so
either the ukrainians had a electronic
intelligence electronic censoring that
caught up the
the signals from that ship and
interpreted it on their own or the most
likely and more likely version
that uh the west state uh the americans
did and passed it on to ukrainians who
who then uh got into action
now does this kind of assistance from
the west increase the risk of russia
escalating its war beyond ukraine
um well
physically russia count
if you have your
army or most of your army bogged down in
ukraine you just can't afford another
war against another country
and you certainly can't afford another
wall against the biggest military lines
on the planet right now which is nato
so
for practical reasons no
of course for legal reasons and
political reasons the provision of
intelligence is
uh of course a a much more sensitive
issue than the provision of arms a
provision of arms for a
party of war is something that is legal
and where you have very clear
sort of benchmarks legal benchmarks
what's allowed what's not uh on
intelligence things become much more
fishy so these are of course inofficial
reports and the us government would of
course decline having done so for very
good reasons
uh but
inofficially of course everybody knows
that this is the case um
but yes it's sort of from the legal side
this is a a much more fishier part
uh on the whole affair than sending
heavy artillery tanks um missiles etc to
the ukrainians
the the kremlin is determined to reach
some kind of milestone by may the 9th
next week now that's the day that russia
commemorates the soviet union's triumph
over nazi germany
is mariupol that victory and and do you
think russia will succeed in declaring
that a victory
um well it might be
on the other hand you know in a country
where the foreign minister can come out
and say uh other hitler was a jew and
israel is responsible for supporting
nazism
truth doesn't really matter all that
much uh they can declare maria paul as a
victory even though there's still
fighting going on in the city they can
declare pretty much anything to domestic
audience because it's punishable up to
15 years to kind of debunk or contradict
whatever officially stated to it
so uh i i would be rather relaxed about
may 9th yes they will announce something
yes they will do some propaganda scheme
but that's about to be expected uh i
think neither the russian military nor
the ukrainian military uh have a a
timeline in their planning offensive and
defensive that is tilted towards may 9th
okay we'll have to leave it there gustav
kressel from the european council on
foreign relations thank you so much
thank you very much
now ukrainians living under russian
occupation are being faced with a stark
choice should they resist russian
authority or risk reprisals or should
they embrace their new leaders a team
from french public tv recently traveled
to one such community in southeastern
ukraine and what they found were people
who after fighting the invaders just a
few weeks ago are now choosing their
words very carefully
mario paul in southeastern ukraine those
who reduce the city to rubble now bring
aid
everything was good and functioning now
everything is destroyed
don't talk nonsense
she is only here to provoke aren't you
here for the aid what are you talking
about
there is tension in the air but somehow
life carries on in the russian occupied
areas of ukraine
people are even getting married
like here in berdyansk 80 kilometers
from mariupol
these are the first weddings since the
war began
now the flags are red white and blue
instead of blue and yellow
it's on show for the world to see
the russian anthem plays for the wedding
ceremony
and the bride and groom
beam with joy
[Music]
it's an important day for the city
and for us
and we are very proud of the country
of which country the french journalist
asks
russia
the marriage is marked by celebratory
gunfire while just a few kilometers away
soldiers kill
in occupied areas russia has installed
mayors who say what putin wants
we have a military and civilian-led
administration we see our future with
russia
this is also being demonstrated in melee
topol the central square is draped in
soviet colours ahead of the
commemoration of the red army's victory
over nazi germany on the 9th of may just
a few weeks ago residents protested the
occupation now officially at least
there's barely any dissent
[Music]
i came with the red flag to celebrate
russia's victory i'm not afraid of
anything because we have always lived
well with russia
they have raised new flags
before it was ours and there are always
soldiers here not ours
what do you think about that asks the
french tv crew
it's hard to say we're neutral let's put
it that way
a new era has begun in the occupied
areas of ukraine in some places the
ruble is being introduced as day by day
russia looks to expand its influence
over all areas of life